und wieder so ein Fall von einem Musiker
der sich sehr früh dazu entschieden hat
für nichts anderes als die Musik zu
leben und das bedeutet natürlich eine
Menge Ärger und zwar mit den Eltern und
auch könnte es ja unangenehm sein für
ein Musiker immer mit anderen verglichen
zu werden bei Andreas Bourani ist das
ich und ich und Adel Tawil natürlich und
Xavier Naidoo wie lebt er damit und wie
kommt er mit seiner tierischen und
Pünktlichkeit zu Recht darüber reden wir
jetzt im Interview und über noch viel
mehr
halli hallo hallo
wir haben geklettert wir wollten die als
erstes mal eine kleine Aufgabe geben
das sieht gut aus sehr gut elegant
fantastisch mehr geht nicht Hallo ich
bin Christoph Andreas
die berühmte Frage
ist da ähm Sommer ist zurück mir geht's
wunderbar wie lange ist es jetzt
eigentlich schon auf dem Markt ich habe
das
jetzt fast mehr als ein Monat und läuft
ja wahnsinnig oft im im Radio ja nur in
meinem Kopf ne genau ja ja hast du das
erwartet nee überhaupt nicht also das
ist was was man ja auch nicht planen
kann man weiß ja vorher nicht gerade
beim Schreiben schreibt man ja irgendwie
einfach ein Lied und überlegt sich was
was will man sagen und weiß aber ja
niemals was dann passiert damit ne so
wenn man das dann irgendwie das dann die
Plattenfirma und die
promoten ist dann also das kann man
nicht abschätzen also hat man nicht beim
Schreiben so ein Gefühl ja das wird
ganz ehrlich eigentlich bei jeder Nummer
also bei bei mir war es wirklich bei
allen 13 Stücken aber ich glaube das ist
auch wichtig dass man auf auf seinen
Werk und was man dann geschaffen hat
auch stolz ist ja dass man das irgendwie
abfeiert und sagt ja ist mir gelungen
ist ein gutes Stück geworden so ja aber
bei dir ich sag mal so nach dem langen
Leidensweg
ja ja teils teils also ich habe nicht
nur gelitten die ganze Zeit aber ich
habe schon eine Weile gebraucht
natürlich jetzt ist es bis es zu der
Veröffentlichung jetzt kam da gab es
definitiv Höhen und Tiefen ne hast du
hat man dann trotzdem immer wieder das
Gefühl das wird was das muss was werden
oder hat man auch zwischendurch mal das
Gefühl ich muss irgendwo am Band im
Akkord Arbeiten
junge du musst das muss klappen weil ich
habe auch nichts anderes gelernt ich
kann auch gar nichts anderes wirklich
und das mit dem Profi Fußball hat
irgendwie nicht geklappt
genau und ich wusste ich muss das muss
irgendwie ich muss es schaffen ja aber
zwischen ich muss es schaffen und
schaffe ich es gibt ja noch einen
Unterschied ja klar
also was war so die tiefste Tiefe und
was war die höchste Höhe so dazwischen
ja halt einfach so für mich war so
erstmal der Punkt es gibt immer so
Zwischenziele die man sich da steckt und
für mich war es halt einfach wichtig zu
sagen ich hätte gerne einfach mal eine
Veröffentlichung einfach zu wissen okay
dann das ist meine Chance jetzt
und das hat halt vorher nie geklappt hat
dann zum Beispiel ein Album geschrieben
ist da nicht veröffentlicht worden und
so das sind so Rückschläge gewesen die
natürlich dann auch Zweifel halt einfach
in einem vorhoffen man denkt ah ich habe
jetzt irgendwie so so mit viel zu viel
Energie da dran gearbeitet und meine
ganze meine ganze Blut und Schweiß da
reingelegt und es hat wieder nicht
geklappt warum was mache ich falsche
stellt man sich ja fragen ne hinter
Fragezeichen sein Verhalten und seine
Vorgehensweise aber am Ende wie gesagt
sie habe ich mich dann immer wieder
darauf konzentriert auf die Musik das
hat mir sehr viel Kraft gegeben nicht
immer wieder zurückgeholt an den Punkt
und gesagt ich möchte unbedingt auch auf
die Bühne ich möchte live Spiel das ist
was ich hätte gerne mein eigenes
Publikum irgendwie dass Leute auf
Konzerte kommen und das das dieser Drang
war so groß dass mich einfach immer
dahin gezogen hat auch wieder und was
hast Du zwischendurch falsch gemacht was
war die Antwort auf die Frage was habe
ich falsch gemacht ich glaube dass man
da gar nicht so den Finger auf gewisse
Dinge legen kann dass man sagt das war
jetzt falsch und da hast du was falsch
gemacht das ist einfach auch eine
Aneinanderreihung von ähm ja auch von
Zufällen natürlich auch was man Leute
trifft am Ende braucht man ja einfach
ein Team und Leute die an die eigene
Arbeit glauben die sagen es finden wir
gut das
glauben wir dran und das wollen wir
unterstützen und aber auch von der
eigenen Seite her dass man als Künstler
auch eine gewisse Entwicklung er braucht
dass man irgendwie überlegt ja was will
ich überhaupt sagen was schreibe ich und
in seiner in seiner Arbeit sich auch
verbessert dass man bessere Musik
schreibt
das dass man an Ideen arbeitet also das
sind ganz viele Faktoren ich würde da
gar nicht sagen ja du hast hier das hast
Du falsch gemacht und das ähm das sind
ganz viele Faktoren die da zusammen
fließen und was hast du richtig gemacht
ja das ist jetzt genauso schwierig zu
beantworten eigentlich die Frage wie wir
vorher gestellt hast ich glaube was was
halt wichtig ist ist dass man eine Sache
hat also egal welchen Traum und verfolgt
dass man was tut was man wirklich liebt
wo man wirklich aufblüht und sagt es
darf keine Qual sein das darf sich nicht
nach Arbeit anfühlen das muss Spaß
machen und dass man wirklich eben nicht
aufgibt das war mir immer ganz wichtig
das auch wenn Hindernisse kommen das im
Nachhinein jetzt weiß ich das wirklich
zahlt sich aus dass man an seine Sache
glaubt dass man an seine Ideen glaubt
und dass man seinen Weg geht ja und ich
aufgeht normal noch mal liegt wo war
denn würdest du denn sagen war so ein
Wendepunkt wo du gesagt hast hier hat
sich so alles gefügt und da habe ich
richtig gemacht
das war ich glaube auch einfach mit dem
Team ich habe gemerkt da hat sich
einfach dann gut angefühlt intuitiv dass
ich dann Leute hatte dass die Band war
vom Management das wird der Plattenfirma
zusammen das ist so da merkt man einfach
jetzt ist es gut jetzt jetzt
ich glaube es war der Punkt als ich
gemerkt hatte ich kann meine Ideen so
umsetzen und entfalten wie ich sie
möchte wie ich wie ich mir vorstelle und
das ist mir eigentlich auch während der
Produktion klar geworden das ist ein
absolut kompromissloses Album geworden
es ist genauso wie ich es wie es mir
vorgestellt habe es klingt wie es wie es
wollte das jetzt keine Nummer dabei wo
ich irgendwie sage ja die klingt
irgendwie nicht oh hätte ich da noch mal
irgendwie an der Gitarre oder dies
hätten wir noch mal anders aufgenommen
es ist genau so wie es mir gewünscht
habe und das war vorher nicht so
richtig ja vorher gab es waren einfach
öfter Kompromisse aber auch eben klar
weil manchmal irgendwie vielleicht auch
Leute im Weg standen oder gesagt haben
die nicht an mich geglaubt haben und
sondern kämpft man ja immer auch dagegen
an ne dann ist man ja so ist es nicht so
eine Einheit und nicht jedes Zahnrad
greift ineinander und dann wird es
natürlich schwierig die Ideen umzusetzen
wie war das vorher in der Zusammenarbeit
wird man dann so gedrängt du musst ich
sag mal Sommerhit schreiben oder du
musst die und du musst reingehen machen
oder du musst das machen oder
ja war das vorher so und ist es heute
anders dass du sagst ich mache das und
du das unterstützt am Ende ist es ja
immer diese Reaktion mach doch mal das
macht doch mal dieses ist ja meistens
steht ja Angst dahinter dass man
irgendwie die Angst davor hat dass man
vielleicht kein Erfolg hat dass man
überlegt was könnte einem zum Erfolg
verhelfen aber das ist ja genau der
falsche Ansatz wenn man hat ja meistens
Erfolg wenn man Kontinuität zeigt und
weil man was macht ja was was innovativ
ist also nichts was wo man guckt was ist
erfolgreich und ich kann das vielleicht
kopieren oder was mir davon nehmen am
Ende ist es hast du recht es ist auch
ein Punkt aber auch es gibt auch viele
Leute die einmal sagen was man alles
nicht kann und da den Finger reinlegen
ja und das kann auch sehr schmerzvoll
sein die Zeit und das ist zusätzlich gut
ne wenn man irgendwie im Team hat und
man bekräftigt sich und man sagt
irgendwie sich gegenseitig was man gut
dann glaubt daran und hat eine ganz
andere Motivation natürlich ne so das
kannst du nicht was ich nicht kann
ich bin sehr ungeduldig muss ich sagen
ja also obwohl ich selber immer Wahnsinn
unpünktlich bin ich glaube ich war noch
nie in meinem Leben irgendwo pünktlich
10 Minuten ist schon wirklich absolut
großes große Pünktlichkeit bei mir
und ich bin aber trotzdem sehr
ungewöhnlich also eigentlich ist es
schlecht ist
von dem anderen die Geduld erwarten dass
man dann erscheint und selbst ist aber
dann nicht gibt ne man selber braucht
das ist ein bisschen schwieriger aber
dann stand dir das wirklich im Weg schon
dass das ist da gekracht hat oder meine
Unpünktlichkeit und Ungeduld diese
Kombination also die Ungeduld ja weil
gerade
so was jetzt mein Beruf angeht dass ich
sage ich will auf die Bühne Weise
ungeduldig und habe gedacht wieso da so
lange und warum hat sie wieder nicht
geklappt das ist dann was was mich
natürlich auch ähm ja was stand ich mir
dann selbst auch im Weg und mit meiner
Umgebung ständig Probleme ja das ist ja
natürlich klar
nicht außer dass man ja in der als Musik
auch Termine einhalten da gibt's ja
tatsächlich zur Uhrzeiten an die man
sich hält ist ja nicht so dass man da
einen Tag in eine und gerade bei
Radiosender ist es natürlich so gibt es
ein Live Interviews und wenn man dann
nicht da ist dann ist man nicht da ich
habe bisher noch keins verpasst hat dann
immer irgendwie geklappt ja aber es ist
aber sehr hektisch dann also ich muss
dann immer kommt man dann völlig
verschwitze und will ich aufgelöst wenn
du jetzt das so siehst hast du so das
Gefühl hey ich bin da angekommen wo ich
hin wollte das ist das Leben jetzt dass
ich führen möchte oder fehlt dir was ich
glaube gar nicht dass ich sagen würde
das ist das Leben führen möchte das ist
jetzt halt eine Phase ist auch nur eine
Zeit ein Abschnitt meines Lebens
momentan wie die Dinge gerade laufen und
ich denke dass ich das auch verändern
wird also ich glaube es ist ein Fehler
wenn man sagt das ist es jetzt ähm so so
kannst immer sein wenn man sich da so
drauf versteift und festbeißbar ist dann
ist es glaube ich umso schwieriger wenn
es mal nicht mehr so ist und wenn man
ich versuchte so ein bisschen offen für
mich zu halten zu sagen
es ist eine schöne Zeit wenn es gut ist
gerade ich genieße es aber auch eine
Vorbereitung das Leben besteht aus
Veränderung ne das ist ein ständiger
Prozess die Dinge verändern sich
Menschen verändern sich man selbst
verändert sich ständig und ich glaube es
ist gesünder wenn man sich nicht so auf
auf einen auf eine Sache oder eine
Situation ist ein bisschen Freiheit was
war jetzt so der schönste Moment in den
letzten Monaten
also der schönste Moment ist definitiv
gewesen auf der Bühne ich habe ja ich
habe so einen Song den ich immer am
Schluss Spiele Wunder heißt der und da
ist so ein paar dabei so mit uns der
sich super anbietet auch zum Beziehung
und ich versuche dann immer die letzte
Nummer die ich auf der Bühne Spiele und
versuche dann immer auch das Publikum zu
Mitsingen zu animieren und wenn mir das
gelingt das ist wirklich ich liebe das
wenn man so ein riesenchor hatte ich war
auf dem Hessentag da waren 8000 Leute
und wenn die alle mitsingen das ist so
ein riesengroßes es ist echt ein sehr
gutes Gefühl wir sind denn so die
Reaktionen wenn man neu kommt man wird
ja so einsortiert in eine Schublade wo
bist du da gelandet
also ist ganz unterschiedlich ich habe
ich hatte meine Zeit da waren waren die
Haare kürzer dann habe ich öfter Xavier
naido gehört sind so ein bisschen länger
dann kam Adel Tawil oder auch Joachim
Deutschland oder wie auch schon wieder
wahrscheinlich dann eher optisch weil es
mir egal ist ja doch die Musik also da
kommt da kommt wirklich alles so
zusammen aber ich finde das völlig in
Ordnung weil das ist eine ganz
menschliche Sache dass man ja Kategorien
sucht und irgendwie aus Schubladen
öffnet und ja auch irgendwie versucht
dem anderen zu erklären wie klingt er
die Musik und dann muss man ja irgendwas
nennen was man kennt er und sagen ja das
klingt halt immer so so also ich selbst
sage es nicht weil ich finde wir sind
alle einzigartig ist ja schon gesagt ja
im TV
sozusagen
das habe ich schon jetzt das sind so die
Haupt die die eigentlich wobei du auch
ein produzentendienst hast das glaube
ich auch ich und ich schon produziert
habe und aber das macht ja nichts aus
nee du sagst es ist vollkommen okay ja
ich sage immer Musik sprechen ist so
schwierig ist Popmusik ne und wenn ich
dir sagen würde wie klingt die dann am
besten anhören halt ne dann ist dann
weiß man selber kann man sich selbst ein
Bild machen aber wenn man eben wie
gesagt ist ja immer so dass dass man
Dinge vergleicht und versucht irgendwie
Referenzen ran zu ziehen die wie ja wie
klingt das dann so wir hatten ein Umfeld
jetzt reagiert als ich sag mal Familie
und Freunde sagen hey super endlich
geschafft oder wir sind da so die
Reaktion
ja die freuen sich natürlich auch die
Familie meine Eltern sind natürlich sehr
stolz auf mich ja und ähm einige Freunde
auch die haben sich auch so mitverfolgt
dann weg und mir immer die Daumen
gedrückt und natürlich sind die jetzt
sind die sagen super und ja deine Eltern
noch uneingeschränkt weil die waren ja
nicht so zufrieden dass sie die Schule
glaube ich früher hast du Recht da hast
du Recht die waren natürlich nicht
wirklich glücklich damit aber ich glaube
das ist auch ganz ganz klar ich glaube
jeder jeder Elternteil wünscht sich ja
irgendwie für das Kind das ist das ist
ein guten Weg hat ein schönes Leben hat
irgendwann
und wenn man künstlerischen Beruf
ergreift ist halt ein sehr hohes Risiko
Risiko einfach auch dabei man weiß nie
klappt dass es geht wirklich auf und ab
so wie es jetzt ist kann alles nächste
Woche wieder vorbei sein ja okay
vielleicht nächste Woche nicht aber über
den gewissen Zeit übernächste Woche
genau wobei genau
für welches Bundesland super Bayern
gut also du wohnst in Berlin zwar aber
Bayern und man hört den Einschlag sein
bisschen passt also super also
übernächste Woche wird noch nicht vorbei
sein
aber ist es den nicht trotzdem bei
deinen Eltern zum Teil so dass sie sagen
ja ja mal gucken was draus wird hätte
mal besser was ordentliches gelernt oder
ist das jetzt ganz verstummt nee das ist
auch nicht erst jetzt verstummt sondern
schon eine Weile vorher auch weil sie
gemerkt haben auch als ich noch keinen
Erfolg hatte war das schon so dass dass
sie gemerkt haben der will das wirklich
machen
der glaubt wirklich da dran und das ist
einfach sein Traum und da waren die wir
natürlich nicht im Weg gestanden genau
im Gegenteil habe ich da immer
Unterstützung gesagt okay wenn du es
wirklich willst dann du hast unsere
Unterstützung macht es wir wollen ja
auch nur dass du glücklich wirst mit der
mit dem was du tust okay gut also bist
du damit happy dann war das so die
Wendung also das wird ja eine Weile
gedauert haben bis sie ja ich weiß gar
nicht mehr was er da gab es nicht
irgendwie eine Ereignis ja jetzt sondern
einfach hat sich so gezeigt dass ich
sehr ehrgeizig und verbissen da dabei
war mein Ziel zu verfolgen und hat sich
das irgendwann einfach ja und sie
alleine geben genau sehr gut wie sind
denn die Prognosen hat schon irgendein
großer die auf die Schulter geklopft und
gesagt Andreas aus dir wird man ganz
großer oder was hast du das schon gehört
Aussehen wir haben schon viele große
Menschen die größer sind als ich 1,90 m
oder so
nee also ich habe bis jetzt noch keinen
ähm also ich schätze mal in irgendein
irgendwie passiert
stellen sie ja gerne mal neben ein und
sagen das ist doch nicht passiert
nicht so oft auf Partys irgendwie
irgendwo Leute trifft deswegen ja
vielleicht vielleicht kommt das noch und
auch nicht auf jetzt Festivals oder
sowas da bist ja schon öfter aufgetreten
ja aber bisher das ist immer so bei
Festival sondern trifft natürlich dann
andere Künstler und die sind aber oft
natürlich auch mit sich selbst
beschäftigen ja dann auch mit mir weil
ich mich ja vorbereitet
konzentriert man hat einen Soundcheck
dann die Band ist da und es sind Menge
Leute auch da gibt es vielleicht noch
mal kurz ein Interview irgendwie also
hat man selten Zeit dann irgendwie
wieder auszutauschen und sich auf die
Schulter zu glauben dann ähm riecht
immer wenn es passiert ja gerne
was er gesagt super erstmal vielen Dank
ja